hey guys it's mary with another one of
these check it out videos i played a
game over the weekend it's called expand
and i've played this before i played it
a year ago at the last tokyo game show
it was a nice short demo but now the
whole game is out so i thought i'd give
it a whirl you can tell right away that
this is visually minimalist it's mostly
black and white geometric shapes and
patterns I'm the colored little square
guy in there and the gameplay is pretty
simple you just don't want to get
squished and you don't want to hit any
red stuff it seems pretty easy but the
game is played within a circle and the
whole circle rotates so you to
constantly be on guard with what
direction you intend to go eventually
the patterns get more complicated and
you can even get a bit disorienting
because there should be so many things
going on visually so the difficulty does
increase also for every mistake the game
slightly rotates the angle so you have
to move on the fly can't just use
blatant muscle memory one of the main
aspects of the game that stuck out to me
was the atmosphere which is a product of
the clean visuals and incredible dynamic
soundtrack music is very thoughtful like
you're on the verge of a breakthrough
for each puzzle the music he's kind of
cheering you along its ethereal and it's
meditative it's just not stressful so
even in times we've been working on a
section for a while you might think
you're getting frustrated the music is
motivating for you to complete that
section
there was a few times so there were long
sections about any checkpoints and these
areas instead of feeling challenged
sometimes I just want to get through it
because I already knew what I needed to
do but if I made any tiny mistake when
all the way back and I had to do it all
over again so that could break my
immersion just a little bit also there's
a few sections that felt too easy like I
was just going through the motions I
knew exactly what I needed to do I was
just kind of mindlessly doing it but
overall for a short for our experience I
was still completely intrigued and
interested until the very end I just
kind of sat down and enjoyed it from
beginning to end this game is pretty
inexpensive it's six bucks on steam
right now and I think it's even on sale
so you can pick up for under five I
think expand is polished and it's
elegant you won't see loading screens or
jarring titles it succeeds in creating a
reflective and thoughtful atmosphere I
found myself really relaxed the whole
time it's a very different type of game
probably not for everyone that I thought
it was a wonderful way to spend my night
I hope you guys got something out of
this short overview let me know if you
are interested in playing expand in the
comments below thanks